it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we show you some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts during this
black history month we are also sharing
some products from black owned
businesses to start shopping scan the QR
code on your screen right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner is here as always but then we
have a special guest too that's former
NFL player Reggie Kelly for 13 Seasons
tied in with them big old men she
shaking my hands with let's catch a
football so the Cincinnati Bengals and
the Atlanta Falcons he's also the
founder and owner of kyvin foods which
he's here to tell us all about and it
smells delicious so let's get this
started what do we got absolutely thanks
for having me here Nate Melissa before
we get started y'all make sure you grab
yourself a plate okay like we do it in
Mississippi okay we got some honey apple
salsa for you guys so sweet potato
barbecue sauce no Reggie I saw a cherry
Apple can i cherry can I do that one you
can definitely do the cherry Apple can
you hand it to me Gail you're gonna let
him get
you know guys when I was a kid I grew up
next door to my grandmother and my
family always told me baby when you cook
make sure you do it with love so I long
to pass down to my kids Kyla and Kevin
and everyone and that's how you got the
name of the company that's how we got
that that's awesome it's good absolutely
you like it is it on point oh it's on
point so I want to pass down to
everybody the gift that's been passed
down to me and appreciation for good
food now y'all got to dive into the
honey apple salsa as well the pineapple
salsa favorite robust Tomatoes Golden
Honey for you honey yes awesome apples
all right so you guys dive into it I
like that man and listen I'm supposed to
be the charismatic one up here
doing a couple of my moves right now but
hey you know listen you know I've
enjoyed my transition from football to
food or as I like to call it from the
Gridiron to the cast
[Music]
though Cherry apples very good and why
are these all cooked in small batches so
we cook them in small batches to retain
the flavor the quality and all the
nutrients as well all right with our
products you're not only getting a great
tasting product but you're getting some
health benefits from it as well honey up
as well like in our sweet potato Barber
where were y'all on Sunday when I needed
that's right this is that's right the
Super Bowl delicious but all these fresh
ingredients
apples honey gluten free no high
fructose corn syrup so we're hitting all
all we're checking all the boxes on all
these particular products and you guys
got to try the sweet potato barbecue
sauce guys you've got to try the sweet
potato we actually use wholesome sweet
potatoes it's like a well orchestrated
Symphony oh the right notes on this one
delicious delicious seriously thank you
we appreciate it no jokes that is all
right so really special right now up to
50 percent off on these products
starting at just 22.49 three packs five
packs you better hurry up cbsdeals.com
because these are going to go fast I
recommend a seven pack right the MVP has
everything has everything where can
people buy these online cbsdeals.com
these are very good he's got
he's got Elizabeth what else do you want
yes all right so this is track Grabber
now this is an important tool to keep in
your car if you ever get stuck in the
sand the snow the mud you're able to
actually take this traction device put
it onto the wheel of your car and all
you have to do is start up that car hit
the gas and this is going to allow you
to get yourself out of that tight spot
so think about mud sand snow it's
difficult you would need a tow truck tow
trucks cost a lot you'd have to wait a
long time for the tow truck to come so
it serves as a grip of the tire that's
right it goes right going and boom
you're out that's it and think about
jumper cables think about those
important things that you have in your
emergency kit in your car your kids
should have this your parents should
have this so track Grabber up to 29 off
starting at just 44.99 and cars trucks
SUVs there's a set for you that's really
good kids and your parents should have
that Elizabeth yes that's right that's
right so what do we got here okay so now
mentioned this minted cosmet is made for
everybody from fair skin to Rich skin
this is a black founded and black owned
company they wanted everyone to be able
to find themselves and see themselves in
the world of beauty how important is
that so there's a perfect shade for
everyone actually my makeup today is all
minted okay it's pigmented beautifully
and this is the way that you get that
high quality gorgeous high-end makeup
but at an amazing price so right now up
to 30 percent off starting at just 10.50
beautiful highlighters mascara lip
glosses even beautifully angled brushes
to get that perfect Contour on your face
so this is for I think Katie's getting a
home pedicure yes all right so all right
so Evo and I know you think it's really
good with the foot massage and
everything I remember you told me that
so this is Salon step and this is a
great way to do a pedicure or do your
nails at home so yeah isn't this amazing
so it folds flat for storage but you can
actually you can tap right there on on
the right there's a little button this
has a magnifying light with glass the
little fan for your foot it's all
adjustable so you bend stretch whatever
it might be that you need to do
this yeah so this one 40 off just 20.99
I don't know what Tony's going to be
doing for balance that's right
Kelly my man thank you so much and of
course we partnered with all these
companies to get these deals head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping right
now thank you so much I'm about to get
at these ribs yeah we will see you
tomorrow Happy Valentine's Day